really quick to someone else who
apparently was censored by Twitter he's
the founder and president of Turning
Point USA we just told you that Barry
Weiss a few moments ago reported that
internally Twitter censors set Charlie
Kirk's account to do not amplify status
Charlie Kirk joins us right now Troy
thanks so much for coming on do you I
you're just hearing this too I mean this
just happened this is happening in fact
as we as we talk about it yes but do you
have any idea which of your tweets
set
this censorship in motion
I could probably guess you know a couple
years ago axios did a study that showed
that our Twitter account had was the
fourth most engaged Twitter account on
the planet right up there with President
Trump I mean I've been using Twitter for
a decade happened to understand it
really well and we were averaging 115
000 retweets a day when we were really
at our Peak and we would talk about for
example in the midst of the virus how
lockdowns might not be the best decision
we started talking about how hey I asked
the question are there other treatments
that we might want to talk about so it
could have been that but then all of a
sudden we saw off a cliff almost
immediately our engagement our retweets
disappear I started to talk about this a
lot Tucker and I was called the
conspiracy theorist I was smeared and I
started the email that I pre yes exactly
you're you're Q at non I'm like wait
hold on a second I used to get 115 000
retweets and then it's kind of one of
those things right Tucker where they
convince you to stop talking about it
because you sound like okay who cares
about your Twitter account not a big
deal and now you see actual verified
documents where my Twitter account was
labeled as do not amplify NSFW which I
could only infer means not safe for work
other like threat tags they're treating
my Twitter account with more scrutiny
and censorship than the prime minister
of Iran then Hamas then people that do
actual terroristic type damage and now
we have evidence to show that's exactly
what my Twitter account the last couple
years has been down 95 percent in
engagement they saw what I had to say as
a direct threat to the regime
so there's a huge amount of unfiltered
hardcore pornography on Twitter I think
to this day but it was your Twitter
account that was not safe for work
apparently apparently asking questions
about our lockdown policy which
obviously hurt children and hurt our
target audience at Turning Point USA
college kids where they had to go home
and stare at a screen all day long and
turned in the most suicidal depressed
alcohol and drug addicted generation in
history I started tweeting about that
apparently that was a threat now my
question though Tucker is were they told
to do this by Anthony fauci that is told
to do this by the federal government was
my tweet somehow able to create viral
counter messaging to what they wanted to
see happen in 2020 we may never know but
Twitter at its best when it was really
something that was worthy appreciation I
hope it gets there soon was a place
where heterodox ideas were able to
spread instantaneously with virality and
hold powerful people accountable I
happen to have one of those accounts for
a couple years and Twitter Twitter went
out of their way to censor it and
suffocate our account let me ask did you
ever complain because because you you
understand the platform so you knew that
something in inorganic was happening
something fake was happening yes someone
was putting a thumb on the scale did you
complain to Twitter about it yes I did
so I had a very warm meeting with some
of the Twitter employees back in the
summer of 18. I actually met with Jack
Dorsey personally where he assured me
shadow batting wasn't happening and I
didn't really believe him at the time
but I said okay whatever because I
wasn't really experiencing a lot of what
we consider censorship and then six
months later 12 months later I saw their
contact information and I started to
write them like hey guys something's not
right here silence and then the virus
happened in 2020 and it would you could
not get a response out of Twitter and
then you would start to tweet at Jack
and tweet at the Twitter management and
it was almost as if it became a wholly
operated company that tran that kind of
changed their modus operandi from being
somewhat of a social media platform to a
Democrat Super PAC
and I don't think they really cared and
Elon praised God for his courage and his
bravery revealing this and I try to get
lawmakers involved and other people and
I don't think we'll ever be able to
measure the impact of what Twitter did
to our voices online in the calendar of
2020 the lives that were lost the kids
that really had speech impediments and
delays and school closures and of course
the outcome of the 2020 election all
came from a censorship regime from
Twitter that's totally right and Twitter
did this we learned last week partly
because everyone who works there is a
liberal but partly because Democrats in
Congress threaten them if they didn't do
this republicans in Congress just sat
back and talked about the free market
useless as always Charlie Kirk great to
see you tonight thank you thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight